bonsoir en amélioration vient de le dire
double risque pourquoi ce duel
fratricide alors que vous des deux
fidèles de françois mitterrand et
franchement on voit mal ce qui vous
sépare des enjeux de pouvoir croit pas
qu'il faille après votre duel ou alors
la démocratie n'a plus de sens que si
chaque fois qu'on vote s'est qualifiée
de duel fratricide où va-t-on il y aura
voté il se passera dans la sérénité et
je le pense dans de très bonnes
conditions et la différence entre le
parti socialiste et le rpr c'est qu'à la
sortie au parti socialiste il n'y aura
qu'un candidat et pas de et celui qui
sera désigné sera je le crois vraiment
soutenu par tous les socialistes
que ce soit les militants base où les
responsables et je l'espère par maximum
de personnes de femmes et d'hommes à
gauche tenez 500 jeunes pardon est ce
que n'avait pas le sentiment que même
que dans l'opinion publique les dégâts
sont d'ores et déjà irrémédiable quand
on entend dire comme tout à l'heure que
le courant ne passait pas où passer de
plus en plus mal alors qu'aujourd'hui
moi j'ai présidé un bureau national
extrêmement responsable et serait et pas
du tout agitée je pense que ça peut
faire des dégâts puis il a eu aussi des
comportements qui n'ont pas ils ont
toujours été serait cet évident quand
ségolène royal à vis d'elle elle pourrit
de côté ce scrutin alors qu'elle était
président du conseil national et que
jean glavany dit elles n'ont rien elles
mêmes minorités dans sa section ça sent
pas la rente amour tout de même pas il
ne faut pas surestimer tout ça tout à
l'heure on regarde et un sujet d'une
gravité terrible et je crains aussi dire
que par rapport à tout ça ça se passait
bien dérisoire de surcroît monsieur
masure on comprendrait que je ne dirai
de mal d'aucun socialiste et que je ne
suis pas venu pour faire la campagne
interne du parti socialiste si vous le
permettez sur switch je voudrais dire un
mot parce que dans ces images on ne peut
pas rester silencieux
je voudrais dire que j'ai la conviction
qu'on ne guérira jamais nos switch parce
que
le côté le plus tragique c'est que ce
sont des hommes qui ont fait ça c'est à
dire des êtres qui appartenait à autre
espèce est quelque part quelque part
nous avons tous une inquiétude une
question qu'il n'y ait pas de réponse
mais on peut revenir aux hommes et aux
élections présidentielles où il est d'un
mot parce que nous sommes assez serré ce
soir caisse pour
est-ce que vous pouvez expliquer d'un
mot français ce qui vous sépare de lien
juste passer un ou simplement après une
forme d'alliance avec le mouvement
radical vous êtes plutôt pour une
altération de la gauche non communiste
ce caoutchouc moi j'ai pris mes
responsabilités en tant que premiers
secrétaires parce que je souhaite le
rassemblement des socialistes ça me
paraît une condition indispensable et je
souhaite aussi autour du candidat
désigné par les socialistes
rassemblement le plus large possible de
la gauche je pense que c'est ma
responsabilité en tant que premier
secrétaire du parti socialiste de mener
ce combat majeur est de promouvoir ce
rassemblement est aussi d'être le
porteur de la ligne politique j'ai fait
adopter par près de 90% des militants
dernier convié vert donc j'ai la
conviction que tout ça est important et
je suis un homme qui ne se résignent pas
et qui ne se résignera pas à ce que la
droite occupe dans ce pays tout le
pouvoir à ce que la victoire de monsieur
balladur comment l'annoncent la
claironne mais les sondages sont bons
pour un jour ils donnent la température
du jour mais ils font pas la météo dans
les trois mois que ma victoire monsieur
balladur dont à la droite tout le
pouvoir au plan national
au plan local et je dirais aux plans
d'économies je ne me résigne pas à la
régression sociale
je ne me résigne pas à l'exclusion au
chômage à la précarité
j'arrête là nous aurons d'autres
occasions mais il ya beaucoup de choses
auxquelles je me résignerai pas je veux
qu'on se bat
je veux que la gauche gagne et je pense
que ce n'est pas impossible parce que je
sais que dans la côte de popularité
monsieur balladur
il ya davantage résignation que
l'espérance merci henri minuit donc vote
désignation l'autre week-end le week-end
du 4-5 février c'est cela je vous
rappelle que lionel jospin sera demain
le premier invité de notre émission
politique du jeudi intitulé carnet de
campagne